this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by hawthorne raycon
upstart manscaped and expressvpn
more on that later let's get into the do
the honeydew
with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we
are over here
doing it at the night pants studios i am
ryan sickler ryan stickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com
um and again i'm just going to say it at
the top again thank you
for real i mean i can't thank you enough
this is so much fun
i love laughing at this [ __ ] there are
some horrible things people have said
that have just made me laugh
incredibly hard and uh i can't thank you
guys enough for the support i know it's
helping i i didn't know it at first and
i believe it now so thank you for making
me a
a believer in it all um and please if
you
haven't already subscribed go subscribe
to the youtube page
um you'll get video there every tuesday
we drop that audio on monday
um and the patreon it's five bucks a
month it's called the honeydew with you
all there's no tears no levels none of
that [ __ ]
all right you ain't getting a t-shirt
none of that crap it's just five bucks a
month
if you're looking for extra content i do
two shows a week
and that is an episode with y'all called
honeydew with y'all where i highlight
the lowlights with y'all so if you
or someone you know has that [ __ ]
story that just
has to be heard please email me at
honeydewpodcast
gmail.com excuse me and uh we'll
definitely read those stories and
hopefully we'll get to do an episode
together
um the honeydewpodcast.com is the
website here the social media make sure
you're on the facebook fan
page follow me all over and blah blah
blah all right
but night pants nation i mean come on
y'all y'all turned
something so stupid and funny into
something real
and that's the magic all right and then
you cut them off at the knees and made
night shorts i
y'all are the [ __ ] okay y'all are the
[ __ ]
i hope you're comfortable as hell out
there night pass nation i appreciate you
all during the summer
and night shorts nation uh go get your
merch
and rep the show um and speaking of
repping i always love to rep
uh santa monica music center i record
here every week
and if you want to take some online
music lessons go to santa monica music
dot com
use code honeydew they will give you uh
the registration fee
completely waived and a free lesson when
you sign up for a package they're
fantastic
i love them here we're doing good things
for the kids
uh now you know what we do here we
highlight the low lights these are the
stories behind the storytellers today is
a bit of
a bittersweet episode uh one of my
oldest and dearest friends here is back
uh for you know going away for a little
bit here ladies and gentlemen
i'm going to prison i mean it feels like
it bro it feels like it's steve simone
y'all
back on the honeydew so good to see you
oh i love you dude i do you know i love
you too
it's weird that we're doing this as a
podcast though because i thought we were
just going to hang out
yeah and then you were like you want to
do and i was like okay why not why not
why not this is an end of an era for a
lot of people
there's a lot of you guys leaving uh you
you do plan to come back at some point
maybe yeah
i mean the only way i can wrap my head
around what's going on
is i'm telling myself this is a
temporary move because
i got nothing in la right now like the
city is shut down for people that don't
i mean there's you can't get a haircut
church is outside
if you can't eat outside of the
restaurant guess what that restaurant's
done
so uh it's an expensive city
all my friends i think i have like three
buddies that are gonna be here
everybody else i know is going and um
when joey joe our uncle joey when joey
diaz was
i mean i've known joey for 20 years and
we actually don't live that far from
each other in the valley
so during quarantine he was my my link
to sanity
and we would see each other a few three
four times a week
keep each other we would just trade food
like baseball cards i built joey you got
to try this
oh dog tremendous i'm gonna go get you
some clams can you do a linguini with
white clay i never made it
phenomenal home run he's he's been
ordering to jimmy's crab cakes and
call me about it like loving every bit
yeah he is
he left me up with one of those crab
cakes it's one of the best things i've
ever i'm telling you dude
they are the [ __ ] um he let me be the
first ever
guest host i can't even like that's an
honor
dude it's the end of it a big deal um
yeah it really was
um and i told him we're not stopping
your life story i don't care we'll zoom
he will be a zoom
yeah we're gonna take care of that dude
but uh so look this is the way i look at
it so joey and i were hanging
and then around june so it was march
april may he was going you're doing the
right thing stay here
because my game plan was i thought rents
were going to drop in la
i thought okay 40 of the city is
technically unemployed right now
that some of the statistics were that
high and i went a lot of people had
already left la
there were people at the beginning of
covet that were like you know what i'm
out i'm gonna go live with my parents
i'm gonna go back to
whatever so my rents will come down and
joey was like yeah
dean delray found a place that was this
much now it's this much
so i thought i was going to be able to
find a more affordable housing
and i also really had hoped that some
sort of innovation
was going to happen with like a a live
streaming stand-up show which they're
doing but also
i thought at some point by may or june
we were going to have limited inside
comedy clubs
maybe socially distance with people with
masks and then i was like
you know if they stream that show and
there's a live audience because
i need an audience to play too i can't
just stand in front of a camera and do
stand-up i'd feel like an idiot
but i thought okay that's going to be an
exciting next
next step of what the future of stand-up
comedy might be
and i really thought whatever was going
to happen in stand-up
the comedy store would still be the
epicenter and
uncle joey would be at the forefront so
essentially i was like whatever joey's
doing i'm doing
that's kind of how i was getting through
covet
and then in june he started to tell me
it's time to go for me personally
he was like just go to your mother what
are you doing be with your family
there's nothing going to happen here he
goes my every show i had has been
canceled
this is bad this is worse than anybody
saying
so but i know what a pain in the ass
moving is and i didn't want to do it
you know if i didn't have a a family
here i'd be gone
i'd be gone what's there is nothing here
right now that's why i want to right
yeah
yeah because i've really been thinking
about this because i've been reflecting
it's been almost 20 years to the day
that i've spent in l.a like almost 20
years to the day
and i think the real gift of los angeles
at least the la that i knew that brought
me out here
is the great meeting of minds all these
comedians like that's what i wanted to
pursue but
everybody from all over the world comes
all these broken
[ __ ] up twisted amazing
beautiful divine hilarious hilarious
individuals yes
and i'm just not gonna get that anywhere
else in the world no you're not
you're not gonna get up the
so that's what i'm like i'm like i have
to come back like when the comedy store
comes back
i'm gonna come back but when joey is the
most i think he's a prophet
that's just my personal feeling i think
god has touched him
so i think when he's telling me to leave
i almost have like this biblical fear
that it's time for me to go
like that's i know that sounds crazy but
that's how i feel
so joey's the most street smart dude
i've ever met
and he was telling me about the crime
that he had started to see
and then you know joe rogan's more of a
hero than a friend
you know but he's one of the smartest
dudes i've ever met
and he has access to the most brilliant
minds
of this generation generations like
every week that dude's talking to
another genius
right so when the smartest guy i've ever
met who interacts and has the most
the best informed opinion on los angeles
when he's gone
when the most street smart touched by
jesus dude i know
is leaving i'm like what i gotta go so i
didn't want to accept that
and what i've been telling myself is
it's just a temporary move
wait till we get through the election
wait until we get through some of this
covet stuff and things start to open up
hopefully rent will be cheaper
and for now it's a temporary move
just to sort of breathe
a little bit be near my family and uh
sit things out on the sidelines you know
yeah i mean look i i
selfishly obviously you know i love you
and i don't want you to go but of course
i support it 100
so ryan i don't want to go i know you
don't i don't but i'm just going
there's nothing here for me right now no
and it's expensive i'm like i'm just
throwing money out of a window every
month
what sit sit inside and build puzzles
with my girlfriend i'm like
i could do this for half price somewhere
else on the beach
on yeah yeah for real and then
i was trying to make everything work you
know i was like well if i could find
i don't even mind spending this much
money if i found a place i really loved
you know like a place where you go all
right i don't mind spending this much
money throwing it away because it's the
cost of doing business in l.a
and then like two weeks ago my
girlfriend's from the pasadena
area i was up there we're i've been
looking at places up there for months
because she wants to be near her family
and then there's other areas like la
canada a lot
of yeah it's beautiful up there on my
words
and these places look great online and
then i want to go drive by at night and
i'm like i can't live there that's
i can't spend that much money for that
place it's just not gonna happen
and for the first time during lockdown i
had legit anxiety
where i couldn't sleep and i was
draining diet cokes maybe that the
caffeine but it was 4 30 in the morning
and i'm playing chess in my head like
what am i gonna do with my furniture
should i do a garage sale
should i put stuff up on craigslist this
and that
and then the walls started to shake i
was up at 4 30 in the morning
and there was a legit real earthquake
the walls in my apartment literally
cracked that's how close i was to the
epicenter i woke up the next morning
and there's cracks in my walls so i
wasn't
i was really here it felt like i thought
i was just gonna go
and as i was doing that i was thinking
about all my stuff
i really feel like i heard god go is
your stuff really that important right
now
and i'm like nope and he was like just
pack up your car
give away give away your things whatever
doesn't fit in your car give it away and
just
just go for now so right now i feel like
jewels and pulp fiction where i'm just
playing
i'm just walking the earth i'm just
gonna go walk the earth i got gigs
coming up in virginia
um so i figure i can fly to virginia see
my brothers in philly then i have shows
in denver
and then after i'm done with the denver
shows i'm gonna my girlfriend we're just
gonna go to like montana
utah go see old faithful go see all that
stuff yellowstone
some state park yeah just go see some
stuff and look at
this transition as a blessing and then
see what's next
i think it's a a good plan man it's a
whole world's own pause
it is i mean obviously we're more on
pause it feels like than what everyone
else is telling me out there and what
i'm hearing but uh i wanted to share
an embarrassing earthquake story with
you because earthquakes
i always like to think i'm you know a a
man you know what yeah
but there is some [ __ ] that shakes me
literally to my core and earthquakes
have always made my heart like literally
skip a beat
you know pause for something like like
that realize how
powerless you really are when these
buildings are banging and those wall
i've seen what you talked about the
walls bend in
everybody there was one night and i just
hate them
i hate them yeah and i'm laying this is
before my daughter's born or anything
i'm i'm
in my apartment in my bed sleeps like
four in the morning and where i live
was sherman oaks at the time and uh
epicenter was like right in those
canyons
yeah and it might have been on whatever
they called it a
two or a three or whatever but when
you're right there
it's much stronger at the epicenter yeah
off
at least it feels like this one two
weeks ago i was a couple miles away
and it was summer yeah it was summer
like now
and my window was open it's apartment
limits there's other buildings all right
and i screamed
and i came out of it
i came out of a dead sleep i know the
neighborhood i said
oh [ __ ] no and i just ran i screamed
no i ran my ass off but i was like
where am i first one hell no no i was
i got here right after the northridge
hit i was driving here i
left that day and got here there were
massive ones it was 94.
and there were massive uh aftershocks
and earthquakes little ones that would
happen
after that too so i've had my share of
them but
man that one just i hate them you know
what i mean like i hate them
but i'll say this that one you're
talking about i slept through it
the first one it's the first one in two
decades i've slept through well this is
what
has me concerned i only remember three
earthquakes
since i've been out here for 20 years i
only remember three most of them
remember there was one on the fourth of
july i think last summer my mom was like
oh yeah i was like i didn't even feel it
i was literally walking down the street
listening to music
while it was happening i didn't even
know what happened but the only three i
remember my first one
i was living did you ever get to meet
stevie z
he was the comedian with uh cerebral
palsy i don't think so
oh bro i don't think the absolutely
remember that
straight up man you have met some
characters he was my roommate that's
what i'm okay that's where i'm
familiar with it i don't never met him
but that's why i ever tell the vin
diesel story about him on here
i'm not sure but i want to hear listen
let's just go out with a
bang and laughs and [ __ ] and not be all
corona down and everything let's hear
some facts
i want to hear some of your old roofs
you've bet some characters out here
let's hear about them
all right my first apartment was
probably just a couple blocks away from
here it was on berkeley in santa monica
because there used to be a pizza place
at ninth and wilshire called the slice
yeah it was yeah i was in la for two
days my brother's friend was like well
if you're looking for the best wings
in la go to this place the slice and
actually it's probably the best
pizza in l.a one ripe on my overall
santa monica too
yeah so they had to that was before that
one opened up the original was the knife
and will shirt it's not there anymore
so i go in there the guy my buddy who's
now one of my best friends my buddy
brian was behind the counters i
literally just drove in from philly he's
like where are you from like he knew
i was not from here and i was like i
just moved out here from philly he's
like yeah no joke
he's like you are not santa monica at
all so he was like what do you do i say
comedy he goes do you know joe matarese
joe mataris was the only comedian i knew
in the world at that point
and brian had gone to college with joe's
brother they played baseball together at
gw
so we became friends i ate pretty much
every meal there
and he offered me a job delivering
pizzas found me an apartment
uh god i forgot these stories so i lived
down here on berkeley with two dudes i
didn't know
is this the same apartment tracy morgan
made breakfast then no that was a fat
james apartment
you got tracy morgan up in your crib
what's that say about you
like crazy making breakfast shirtless
shirts the littlest nipples in the world
oh i love it
the nipples the size of kittens they're
making burgers
on a george foreman grill scrambling
eggs
fat james cutting heaters and biggie
smalls
shaking the walls at four in the morning
fat james got the party with tracy
morgan yeah he used to call fat james
cookie
hey cookie you know i love you
the best oh tracy morgan loved everybody
man he did
biggest heart in the world so let me
hear about this guy this roommate here
so i'm living there that was my nicest
apartment
the nicest apartment i ever lived in in
la was the first one i lived in
with two strangers and uh
i i told this story once on maybe it was
a crab feast about when my car
died the bad transmission and then i had
to deliver a pizza it was caught on the
hidden camera show
oh yeah that's when i was living at that
place yeah so like i had nowhere to go
and i met this dude paulie sure was
shooting a movie
my first month in l.a was just
ridiculous because i was working at the
pizza place like i got a job right away
working at the pizza place and then i
was doing production assistant work for
paulie on something called paulie
shore's dead
and we were shooting at a vfw in
the deep valley it might have been
[Music]
ah it's all i forget but it's out by
like not
panorama city i knew you were going to
say i was just gonna say we just talked
about this on another episode about
panorama studios with santino's
it's a different world over there bro
they were like you should get a job here
like at the vfw they'd like
you'd be a great bartender because
they'd still let the old dudes in there
and drink
even though they were shooting a movie
and there was a dude waiting outside
who was going to be in the scene of the
movie and he was wearing a philadelphia
eagles t-shirt and he had like a
dumbbell gold gold chain and it was my
buddy stevie
who um has cerebral palsy but was also
like a bodybuilding thug
that's no lie
so stevie and i used to watch eagles
games down here at a at a bar called the
shack it was at 26 in wilshire it was a
philadelphia eagles bar
so stevie was like one of my first
friends in la
so when the lease ended on the i moved
in with stevie for 250 bucks a month
he was living in a section 8 apartment
in hollywood
before it got gentrified like it was at
mccadden
and sunset yeah and i remember there
were dudes putting on a roof
on our apartment building and the motel
next door was
all transvestite prostitutes
every time i walked out of that
apartment building like and walked down
the steps i felt like axel rose getting
off the bus
like shooting the jungle baby
like that's what i felt like i remember
like that my
toughest guy ever knew jiu-jitsu vinnie
was like you got to be careful in this
neighborhood this was a bad neighborhood
well anyway that's where my first
uh earthquake experience was i was
taking a shower
and i thought everything started to
shake and i just ran outside naked with
soap in my eyes i didn't know what
i didn't leave the apartment but i
didn't know what to do and it stopped by
the time i was trying to
come up with a game plan but it was
crazy
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor hall hawthorne
now i don't know about you guys but back
in the day
my experiences with cologne were
horrible i'm spraying it all over my
body on places i shouldn't have been
spraying it burning things everything
else back in the day you had like
you know polo obsession all that stuff
uh but hawthorne man hawthorne not just
colombe they've got all kinds of body
products
uh ash has been using stuff from the box
my stepson took both the colognes
haven't been able to get that back
there's shampoos there's everything guys
if you're looking for a product that'll
help you smell
nice and feel good hawthorne's got you
covered ladies
if you're looking to up your man's game
or maybe you all have some teenagers
that are staying home right now and
quarantine stinking the place up
this is the stuff you take a quick two
minute quiz and then hawthorne will tell
you the two colognes that are best for
you there's one for work
there's one for play it is totally
risk-free with shipping
and free returns all right so here's
what you got to do and i'm telling you
again
we had soap shampoo conditioner
body wash two types of clone there's
there's all kinds of stuff you can get
out there okay it's not just cologne
there's all kinds of great products
check out hall thorne at hawthorne.co
all right that's h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot c-o and use my promo code honeydew
to get 10 percent off your first
purchase again
that's h-a-w-t-h-o dot
c-o use the code honeydew you'll get 10
off your hawthorne purchase our next
sponsor is raycon
raycon of my favorite earbuds uh
look hands down i've got two pair and
again
my stepson derek took the other ones i'm
listening everything on them right now
but i'll tell you what sounds smooth and
buttery on there
the honeydew y'all sounds good listen to
your new music listen to everything
that's out there right now and uh they
are premium wireless earbuds
and they're half the price of the other
guys i fully recommend them
uh i got raycon's newest model the
everyday e 25 ear buds they're the best
ones yet they've got six
hours of play time seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass there's a more compact
design
a noise isolating fit raycon earbuds are
stylish they're discreet they don't have
any of the dangling wires or stems
the company was co-founded by ray j and
celebrities like snoop dogg
mike tyson uh they're all obsessed with
the products okay you give them a try
raycon has a 45 day free return policy
so you can make sure they're the pair of
wireless earbuds for you
for a limited time get 15 percent off
your order
at buy ratecon dot com slash honeydew
that's b u y
r a y c o n dot com slash honeydew
for a special 15 discount on raycon
wireless earbuds
make sure to check it out now while the
deal is still running by raycon.com
honeydew our next sponsor is upstart you
know how i feel about upstart they're
the best man you guys have been getting
the loans out there i've emailed you
back about it i'm so glad you're
you're taking care of yourself
financially and everyone needs to during
these economically turbulent times
everyone's looking for a way to feel
more financially secure so if you're
still needlessly throwing money every
month at high interest credit
card debt it's time you checked out
upstart the revolutionary online lending
platform that knows you're more
than just a credit score now is the time
to find out how low
your upstart rate can be to help pay off
high interest credit card debt
unlike other lenders upstart can reward
you based on your education and your job
history in the form of a smarter rate
you don't need a degree or diploma to
apply though upstart lets you skip going
to the bank because it's completely
online they offer loans
from 1 000 all the way up to 50 000 so
you can consolidate your debt
into one easy fixed rate payment upstart
makes it fast
and simple to check your rate and since
it's just a soft pull it does not affect
your credit score
the hard pull happens if you accept your
rate and proceed with your application
and the best part
is if the loan is approved and accepted
most people get their funds
the very next business day over 400 000
people have used upstart to pay off
credit cards
or meet their financial goals free
yourself from the burden of high
interest credit card debt
and get back to using your money your
way
with upstart see why upstart has a 4.9
out of 5 rating on trustpilot and hurry
to upstart.com
honeydew to find out how low your
upstart rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes that's upstart.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
anyway stevie was one of my best friends
but he was a thug
and uh like why what do you mean was he
what would he do he would like okay this
is a true story yeah what sort of thug
[ __ ] did he do
all right so i was fortunate enough very
early on in my career where i was
paulie sure was letting me open up for
him i may have
still been sell no this was 2001.
so uh i get to emcee for paulie and we'd
go out on the road sometimes for two
three weeks at a time
now the night before i'm gonna go out on
the road
i hear a female voice at like two
o'clock in the morning with stevie and
i'm like
oh stevie's hooking up right so
uh i'm like great all my bags are packed
i have to get out and take an early
flight i go back to sleep
i leave two three weeks later i come
into my i used to always take a taxi
from the airport to the comedy store
i wouldn't even go home i'd go straight
from the airport to the comedy store and
tell everybody what the road was like
like i felt like travolta in greece when
everybody's like tell me
more tell me more they're like what's
peoria like you know what i mean because
we're doing these
and coming off the road i forget that
i've been the
20 states or whatever in the last three
weeks i forget the night before i left i
hear a female voice
so i walk into my apartment it's
probably two o'clock in the morning
stevie's passed out
and there's a chick in there scraping
bong resin trying to smoke
what was ever left of the weed they were
smoking and i'm like
oh and she was like hi i'm paradise i'm
stevie's friend
paradise paradise almost paradise
we're knocking on him and stuff all
right
so i'm like oh so the next morning i'm
at
like stevie catches me or something
before i go to work
and he was like look that's my friend
paradise she came into town for my
birthday she's going to be gone in a
couple days i go was that the chick
she's like yeah she's been here for like
two three from welcome to the jungle to
paradise city bro
[Laughter]
well turns out she was a stripper slash
prostitute okay and they would get
they'd get drunk and get in the vicious
fights these two would fight each other
yeah these two would fight each other
cerebral palsy
yeah and paradise yeah and i'm like this
is not
suburban philadelphia anymore i'm like
this how did this become my life i just
wanted to tell jokes and
every night i can hear domestic
situations on the other side of the wall
and uh i talked to stevie about it i'm
like hey stevie
this is no good and he was like yeah
she's going to get her own place
i'm not i go this is paradise
this is the opposite of paradise
i don't know what your idea of paradise
is
yeah it ain't this [ __ ] it was
and this is after 9 11 like life was not
good
and you actually had to sit down and
talk to him about it i love that i love
that you communicate with everybody it's
so it's a
great quality it really is well i didn't
like dude i got to the point where i was
leaving i would grab my checkbooks and
my passport
and never kept cashing me apart i would
never leave anything there
that could not be replaced so and we
were already [ __ ] we were already
cramped he was sleeping on a futon in
the living room and i was sleeping in
the bedroom
and i'm like this isn't this isn't a
healthy environment
you can't have a third person who lost
your paradise [ __ ] all in your bed
when you were gone
ugh thanks i never ever
every time you were out they weren't
talking in your bed
oh [ __ ] yeah
all right so
so we finally have to have a real heart
because he tells me she's going to be in
town for two days
a week later i got to talk to him now
it's a month so she's essentially lived
there for two months
not paying rent and just fighting with
them so
i i take him outside and we have a talk
and i
started to explain why i didn't think
that she was a good person to cohabitate
with and how i didn't
feel comfortable there and he's just
gone like this he's like yep
everything you're saying makes sense
you're absolutely right
but if i have to choose between her you
i'm gonna choose her
so the next day i just packed up my
stuff that was it
and then was in with fat james and
then i want to go live with fat james
after that
you said you have more i know you have
more fat james story the funniest thing
to me and i'm sorry
i gotta say is that uh i was saying like
something happened with the upload
and it clipped the end of the story when
you for and people were going
what the [ __ ] happened to fat j oh i was
dying i go what happened
oh [ __ ] it was great they fixed it and
and you got to go listen to that
to the fat james wheels story yeah but i
didn't tell you the fat james doughnut
story i don't think so
i don't think so and there was one where
there was bullets flying over our head
with stevie z
i don't know if i told that on uh i mean
feel free to tell both
donuts well i'll just give you the short
version of the bullet story we don't
need to be sure
because we're an hour-long podcast all
right but i don't want to also
here's the thing i'm fine with sharing
everything i've been through
i don't want to ever put somebody else's
business on the street i know we know
yes all right but when you would ask me
is stevie a thug
yeah like he would like smoke weed spend
his money on booze he's hanging out with
prostitutes and then that neighborhood
like i said was rough it was rough
um and there was no i had no parking so
i had to park blocks away and i'm with
stevie and we're
we're having a fight and this is just
the short version of the story you and
him are
yeah we all we would get into oh okay
cause he's my roommate my friend
that's how you know you really are
friends where you can get into a fight
anyway
i don't know if it was kids lighting all
firecrackers or was the sound of
automatic gunfire
there was a different tone to it i was
under the impression in the moment
i never read a police report nothing but
in that moment
i believed automatic gunfire because
we're walking and
it's best to think that anything anyway
yeah
and i mean you could see the muzzle
flashes okay and you heard like yelling
before it happened like
it sounded like a drive-by okay so and i
could out of the corner of my eye i see
muzzle flashing you're like
it wasn't it wasn't firecrackers it was
like yes
so i dive over a parked car
right and i'm between the parked car and
the curb stevie doesn't break stride
and i went to grab him and he didn't
care he was like nope
and he had his own reasoning behind and
i'll tell you that stuff off off the air
but
he was the real deal and he became like
a competitive bodybuilder after that
dude's my hero
he didn't he didn't care to go
no fear
pop plus he probably couldn't have dove
over the car with the house
he pushed me off he's like he was like
nope
he's like losing cult savers get the
[ __ ] off of it
man yeah so did you stay friends with
him after you moved
yeah the last time i talked to him was
about a year ago so who's the donut
story then
that's fact james all right god i feel
like i told this one
maybe i don't know to be honest i hear
so many stories but i don't remember a
fat jam because i think that the last
time we got into fat james i just told
it was wheels yeah wheels the whole
build up to he finally met him and then
he said
how did it happen
and what's up what was what
straight the fat james
i'll never forget the look like he he
this is fat james
what was it what was what
like that it was i couldn't believe and
then the best part is
the anxiety of sitting there waiting
because you know he's gonna say well
oh like please god dawg
oh my god let me hear about the donuts
dude
all right so i loved fat james
but he also drive me crazy right and i
know
on the the last episode i gave the bill
like he would watch
friends in the other room and try to get
me to come out and watch it and he's
laughing
and he used to have this habit
where like he couldn't be by himself you
know what i mean
so he would always want me to hang out
with him and he would
kind of like wake me up in the morning
like he would just start talking to me
my doorway
like hey awake all right so this was
uh
it was awful i was working i i know this
sounds like a lie
but i think it's real and i'm going
through all my stuff
and i'm going through like if you count
stand-up comedy and being on the road in
travel days
i did not have a day off for over a year
because i think at the time i was
working at this pizza place down the
street from the comedy store
i was working at the comedy store and i
don't think i was working at the gym yet
but maybe i was doing telemarketing
there was i always had
for my first 10 years in la i always had
at least two day jobs
i i've worked three to five jobs
seriously
right um since i've been here right
since i've been here
right and i never had like a good
office i never had enough money to take
the time to try to find a real office
job and also people i know that took
real jobs wound up giving up on comedy
so i was
working at least two minimum wage jobs
all the time
and then like if you count different
jobs at the i'm counting the comedy
stores
one job but it was like back then i
found pay stubs
because it's another thing on it we got
25 dollars a shift
to work the door so if i worked that
door on a sunday and got there at 6 00
p.m in state to one or two in the
morning that's still 25
bucks a shift so
i was exhausted i mean i've been running
at that pace
damn near that pace for probably five
years at the time and then that
say 2005 year there was no day off
and i finally have a day where i can
sleep in so i have to talk to james
and i go james you can't
i'm gonna sleep tonight and do not wake
me up
and he goes i don't wake you up i go
james just
just let me sleep i don't know
you know how yeah you've been working a
lot okay buddy i need to sleep
no matter what don't bother me
what if the building catches on fire
james don't be an ass
you know just no for no now i have to
make him repeat it like a little kid
what i go james say no matter what i'm
not gonna wake steve up
okay i gotcha i go say the word
yeah oh you're gonna i got james all
right no matter what i won't break you
up and let's look at an emergency if the
building catching on fire i go fair
enough
i'm going to sleep i'm
asleep i'm done
and then i just i i'm i start i'm
talking and i'm like why
and i'm like what and i'm talking to
james
and i'm looking at him i go james what's
what time is it
it was 8 30 i go 8 30 in the
why are we talking he's like i got i got
the best news i got to tell you the best
news
i go james what did i say and i lose it
like i go from like talking to realizing
what's going on
and now it's steve martin and planes
trains and automobiles
and i'm just kidding and i did i i
crossed the line verbally
i'm like you want to know why you don't
have any friends because you're so
annoying
why do i have to be the only person who
puts up and he's just
taking it and he went from having the
best news in the world to share with me
to just getting crushed and i feel bad
for the things i said and he's just
holding the doorknob and he's just like
this
you're right i should have let you sleep
oh that's right
because it's just that
he goes just that my dad sent me some
extra money
and you've been such a good friend of me
i wanted to
share it with you and take you out to
breakfast but
i'll let you sleep and he closed the
door
and i'm like oh no i'm like i don't care
i'm going back to bed [ __ ] it i would
still like [ __ ]
your scramble so now i'm trying to go
back to sleep and i'm like i don't care
it's not my fault you should never be
nice to him
and then toss i turn
about four minutes five minutes goes by
i go that's it i'm awake
and i open the door and i go let's go
out to breakfast and he's gone
he just left and now i feel like the
worst person in the world
now i can't get back to sleep so now
it's about almost nine o'clock i don't
fall asleep until 11.
he's gone around two o'clock i wake up
and i open my bedroom door i'm like
james and i trip over a box
and it's a box of donuts
he fell back
like yeah i wish i kept that though dear
steve you're the only friend i've ever
you're the sweetest guy in the world i
know how much you like donuts i'm sorry
for waking you up i hope this
makes you feel better it's terrible did
you eat those dogs
got there right you eat them yeah and
i'm thinking about
[Laughter]
tying together like one of the things i
wrote like
if i look at my hours of stand up like
let's say my first one was dedicated to
my brothers
and then my next cd was kind of
dedicated to my mom that my next cd was
kind of dedicated to my dad what i'm
thinking about for my next hour at least
was this was the pre-covet game plan
and the cd would have been out by now
you know was
talking about friends because i i mean
friends are really the best thing in
life you know what i mean it's like
family you get to choose
and i started to really think about some
of the best friends i ever had
or people i never should have met you
know where you look at somebody you go
how i don't even know how i became
friends we should have never met joey
diaz
never met joey diaz i should never
regularly join
roddy piper yeah joey diaz tommy lee
like yeah
no it's a weird weird great thing
great thing yeah it is and that doughnut
story this is
how i was going to end my hour and i
want to reach out to james's dad before
i do it and that's why i feel
like there's some stuff about stevie i
want to share but i don't have his
permission
and there's some other stuff about james
i would love to share and i don't want
anybody to think i'm like
exploiting anybody or i don't you're not
though but this is what
this is true like okay so that donut
story
um so i live with james we were friends
we drove each other crazy but there was
a love there right
like i remember once he hated when i
would bring people over
i remember this like 2002 2003 and aria
shapiro's hanging out
james just drops his pants he's like
it's my house too but he was so heavy
that you couldn't even tell he had tidy
whitey's on it because his belly he had
a kamala belly
like yeah you know what i mean yeah
so um like 2011
i got a phone call from joey ceres of
jimmy and joey's name
of course
they're the absolute greatest guys look
up jimmy and joey
they are the best the best because
there's been so many jimmies
um joey stayed consistent though
consistent heart of gold
love the dude and he called me because
you need to check in on your buddy james
he's not doing well i go what he goes
he's really sick
this was after you guys were yeah i
moved out five years earlier
okay i moved out in 2006.
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our next sponsor manscaped who is
the best in men's below the belt
grooming they obsess over their
technology developments to provide you
the best tools for your grooming
experience that's why manscaped has
redesigned
the electric trimmer the manscaped
engineering team spent 18 months
perfecting the greatest ball hair
trimmer ever created and just released
the new and improved lawnmower 3.0
their third generation trimmer features
a cutting-edge ceramic blade to reduce
manscaping accidents
thanks to manscape's advanced skin safe
technology and when i tell you this is
premium
i mean this is premium your balls will
love it the battery lasts up to 90
minutes
so you can take a longer shave the water
resistant technology allows you to groom
in the shower and one of the coolest
features is the led light which
illuminates grooming areas
for a closer and more precise trimming
and let's not forget about the charging
stand you can show your mower off
loud and proud because this
intelligently designed stand is a
convenient charging dock
powered by usb if you're listening to me
speak
right now i want you to experience it
first hand
trim that junk of yours get 20 off plus
free shipping with code honeydew
at manscaped.com your balls will thank
you
that is 20 off and free shipping with
the code honeydewatmanscape.com one more
time 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use code honeydew
our next sponsor is expressvpn alright
so we all know how expressvpn protects
your privacy and security online right
but here's something you might not know
you can also use expressvpn
to unlock movies and shows that are only
available in other countries so now that
so many of us are stuck
at home it's only a matter of time until
you run out of stuff to watch on netflix
so this whole week i've been using
expressvpn to binge
doctor who on uk netflix it's so simple
to do i just fire up the expressvpn app
i change my location to the uk
i refresh netflix and boom that's it
expressvpn hide your ip address and let
you control where you want sites to
think you're located so you can choose
from almost
100 different countries all right so
think about all the netflix libraries
you can go through but it's not just
netflix
expressvpn works with any streaming
service there's hulu
bbc iplayer youtube you name it there
are hundreds of vpns out there but the
reason i use expressvpn to watch shows
is it's ridiculously fast there's never
any buffering or lag
and you can stream in hd with no problem
expressvpn is also compatible with all
your devices so your phones your media
consoles smart tvs and more
you can watch what you want on a
personal device or on the big screen
wherever you are if you visit my special
link right now
at expressvpn.com honeydew
you can get an extra three months of
expressvpn for
free okay support the show watch what
you want
and protect yourself with expressvpn at
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
so uh i've only
told this a few times on stage because
it's a lot of laughs i'll do the wheel
story
and then uh james didn't make it
okay he had a rare form of cancer
and um
they had like a comedian's memorial form
at
a place in the valley called rocco's
we're all
and james was like so in on the italian
comedy circuit
like it was great it looked like central
casting in there
like a ragu commercial
you know
and i show up and joey is like being the
master of ceremonies and stuff and he's
like oh i'm so happy you made it
look everybody's going to get up there
and talk about james and he goes i would
love if you had a couple words to say
and i'm like i'm not comfortable with it
you know what i mean like
the weirdest thing about me is i don't i
want to hang out with you i love the
fact that podcasts exist and stuff but
this kind of all makes me uncomfortable
and i miss making people laugh i miss
being on stage but i don't miss the
attention
like i have to pray and really try to
figure out what god wants my life
because i don't want to be out there
okay and even at this memorial i just
wanted to be there and pay my respects
right but joey was like look it would
mean a lot if you could get up there and
say something i'll tell you what i'm
going to put somebody up
i'll come check in on you and if you
want to share something
share it because i really think you
should because you know him very well
out of everybody in here and i'm like
okay so he goes you want to do it i go
all right he goes i'm putting you up
next like it's a comment yeah
next time yes i'll put you up next and
there's maybe 200 people in this
i light a candle to give you the time
it's like this i'm not kidding he goes
this next gentleman was very dear
friends with james
he actually lived with james he lived
with james for
four and a half years and you hear the
whole audience go ugh
do you believe that four and a half
years this man's a saint
give it up for the seats i swear to god
i'm sorry to god it's like nobody will
never believe
[Music]
i can't believe this is my life oh my
god dude
and then i told the donut store and
everybody's like that's the perfect
james story
i'll drive you crazy but he had a heart
of gold
you know and i think the reason why i
want to share that if i can get his
dad's permission
it's like share that put it out there
and then like i think the real lesson is
like
love everybody you meet because when
they're gone
like i i miss fat james you know like i
found some old pictures and i'm like
man it would be fun to be hanging out
with that dude right now where he had a
purple suit
tremendous doo-wop voice really that's
right you did say he could sing
oh he his license plate said doo-wop
yeah
he killed it it's weird who you miss
it's weird who you meet and it's
definitely weird who you miss yeah
that is the damn truth like i'm looking
back at this last 20 years
yeah i have to like for me this is just
a vacation
i'm coming back but like there's so much
uncertainty right now
like i was at the comedy store the last
three saturday nights just hanging out
and uh i'm like okay when this place
comes back i'll be back
but i don't know when that's gonna be
and when it comes back
without rogan without joey diaz it's not
the same club
just not gonna be the same club but i
was
conscious of enjoying the last
five year run at that place what a time
man it's insane
insane it was crazy it was
absolutely crazy like i had a buddy of
mine it was
every bit of that who had i had a buddy
of mine i was real smart business dude
and he was telling me it was like hey
man
we're cruise ship he was like just make
as much money as you can because he was
telling me that the economy was gonna
tank a year ago before kovid
and he was like you need to get yourself
a house you need to start thinking about
retirement
and he was like you know he was pretty
much telling me like just be on the road
as much as possible and who cares
whatever
but then he came to visit me at the
comedy store one night and like we're
talking to bill burr and he sees whitney
cummings
is that joe rogan and rogan's like
what's up steve and then after that he
was like
no stay here he was like don't take easy
money on the road he goes just be a part
of this he goes this is incredible
and i knew it i knew it was a really
special place i knew it was a special
time in comedy in general
and uh i don't know man it's gonna be
great to get out on the road and start
seeing people again and start doing
stand-up but
how long do you think it's gonna be
until we can do real shows i have no
idea i have no i mean no one does who
knows
yeah who knows it could be a year
it could be two who knows i mean
i don't know if they're gonna let us but
i imagine until
sports live sports is a thing again and
that's so weird watching sports with no
fans yeah
i mean i listen to baseball
they're shooting all fireworks and
pumping in crowd noise and all so that
sounds yeah fine um but
uh yeah i don't know um
i don't know it's just a weird time but
you know also think about it i look back
at all these old black and white
pictures of people wearing masks their
their pets have masks on it i mean we've
been through this [ __ ] before as a race
a human race
and obviously we haven't been wearing
masks since we've been born so we've
come out of it
so i don't know it's everything goes
like it's gonna be it will come back
but um yeah in the meantime um
it's it's you know it's a different time
for different right a lot of people even
outside of entertainment uh yeah
everybody's called so many people who i
i was thinking about the beer guy the
other night that beer guy don't have a
job right now
you know what i'm saying but why ah that
guy's
cleveland and that was one dude that
left cleveland and they were talking
about
it devastated the economy there and i'm
like
there's nothing right now no baseball no
football you can't go
see anything so many people out how to
work so many people yeah it's a tough
time for a lot of people right now yeah
but uh i am going to miss you dude we've
had a lot of fun [ __ ] times
yeah a lot of fun so i'm glad to hear
you're going to come back i'm here
yeah you know i'm staying right here
it's nothing i'm not close
jumps off you'll have a place with me i
appreciate it if the apocalypse jumps
off i think we're all done
so yeah it don't matter where you are
i'll be i'll stay out here in 75
and sunny you know you can't beat the
weather you can't
no yeah just weird
it's crazy times and it's weird that
like we're doing this podcast
and i was like i don't know what stories
i got and you're like well tell another
fat james story and now i feel like
we're having our sort of like goodbye
with the cameras on it's weird
i don't know crazy you got some more fat
james story
i love that he got to hang out with
tracy morgan oh yeah
cookie huh caught him cookie
dice dice used to call fat james chip
cause he used to call
he told james he should change his
uh state he's used the stage name chips
keebler jr
and maybe that's why tracy morgan called
him cookie
but i don't know i do know the last time
i got to see tracy morgan he just picked
up
i mean does he does that with you too
right mid sentence same stupid thing you
said uh reunited
yep same spot he he it's he's got
the best i don't know what that is did
you go to the playboy mansion with him
not with him i went and when i turned
the coin you know we were outside and
there was friday night
fights live there how did you get to the
playboy mansion
well which time i've been there two
times i want to hear about both
the first time i got to the playboy
mansion because when i first moved here
um this was 978.
so your first time out here was in 94
right after college and then i went back
graduated at taos and finished up
saved what i thought was a ton of money
and five thousand dollars
yeah and headed west in my 1990 honda
civic with original rims
and i fi i stay with my friend rick and
kevin for a minute until i find a place
in the valley
and i move out there and i'm living in
this little like
it is a white trash melrose place you
know what i mean
it's the same layout [ __ ] but it ain't
the same
you know it ain't the same this is the
neighborhood i think i've told you where
i would jog
and all the mexican dudes would tell me
i'm the only white guy in the
neighborhood and [ __ ] and the first
night there the
there's uh the cops come to the building
and tell us that there's some gang
activity in a building a couple down and
there's chalk and a body on the street
where is this van nice this is north
hollywood at the corner of fulton and
sherman way
and also in 19 whatever yeah it's weird
all neighborhoods change right
so it's it's a rough neighborhood and um
this it had these old ass windows these
glass windows those
i've never seen them anywhere over here
but the slats you know what i'm talking
about
they open up sometimes they're frosted
yeah no no screen
yep so i would open them and i'd get in
the shower when i come out of the shower
there'd be like three [ __ ] cats in my
apartment i'm like where the [ __ ] are
these cats coming from so
i start seeing this lady and i start you
know hey man uh your cats are running in
my apartment you know i'm i'm animal
friendly but i don't need three of your
cats coming in pissing and everything
else you know
oh whatever and i'm like oh this [ __ ]
is all sauced up yeah
so it keeps happening and it keeps
happening and then finally she puts a
nasty note on my car
because she says i parked too close to
her space or whatever so i went to her
door and i knocked on her door and i go
look man you got
these [ __ ] cats running in out of my
place so we're either going to be cool
or we're going to have problems which is
it gonna be and she's like we can be
cool and i was like great
her name was debbie and she would come
by my place all the time
sauced up and every night it was a snake
a chinchilla how many animals did she
have they kept coming i'd hear birds or
police
reeked of urine like even when you get
near the front door wreaked of urine
yeah so many cats and everything and
finally she brought a snake and i'm like
get that [ __ ] thing out here and
she's laughing i go
what the [ __ ] do you do yeah what are
you where are you getting these animals
and she's like i'm hugh hefner's uh
number two zookeeper and i was like
bull [ __ ] you're full of [ __ ] you're
just some [ __ ] drunk lady
that likes pets and [ __ ] you know
parakeets
she could have lied but she was clear
yeah she said i'm his number two
zookeeper
and i was like [ __ ] and she goes
what do i gotta do to prove it to you i
go you can let me come to the playboy
mansion
and see what you do and she's like when
do you want to come i'm like tomorrow
and she goes
okay i was like
so i um the next day comes and i
and she gives me the address and i drive
again my 1990 honda civic with the
original rooms i have a
picture of this over to the playboy
mansion the service gate
wow and i ring the thing and i say
uh how did you even find it this is she
gave me the address
yeah do you have one of the thomas guys
i'd never use a thomas guy
i would just drive and sh i knew where
beverly glenn was and she like you take
the first left off of that boom boom and
it's right okay i was like great
so i get there and um i buzzed the gate
and they're like you know whatever the
answer and i say hey i'm ryan sickler
i'm here for uh
debbie and then i don't i hear it hang
up but i'm like i'm [ __ ] doing it and
then the gate starts to open
and i drive that little [ __ ]
honda civic into hugh hefner's driveway
and i park it
in front of the mansion which you don't
get to do i have a photo of it
wow it is parked in front of the mansion
and i'm like you gotta be kidding me so
then she starts
taking i'm like you really do work she's
like yeah i really work here
so she um takes me in like he's got like
almost like a um
i don't know what you call where the
iguanas and the snakes and everything
are um
like for lack of a better term was like
a little rainforest area in a tropical
area small little thing
um but then there were there were um
albino peacocks
and there were um which i had never even
seen and then there was this cage with
these mini monkeys
i'm just going to ask you about monkeys
yeah dude and she have chimps too
no i wouldn't have [ __ ] with you
because they can rip your face off yeah
remember that guy that brought the
birthday
and they ripped his testicles off
no that's a real story where the guy had
like a baby chimp and he donated it to
the zoo
he like hit the chips
yeah because i still want to kind of
have a chimp but i think about that oh
you don't
dude they have the strength like four or
five men
anyway these little monkeys are in this
cage we're in a room like this and
they're way up there you know and she's
she's like i'm gonna step out i'm like
don't step out and she's like i'm gonna
use your cameras back then i had a vhsc
camera though the compact vhs that went
in
and um she's shooting it for me i don't
even know where the [ __ ] that is
and these things just descend and i'm
giving them grapes and they are like
boom on my show boom
and they had the hands were about this
big but it was so creepy it was
yeah it was fleshy and it would touch
your skin i was like well
it'd be like these many many mini hands
yeah
so then raccoon hands yeah but fleshy
you know like feeling like our skin yeah
um so then she took me in um
into like the play room and like this
this it was just a
[ __ ] room and the the floor it must have
been this
thick padded like you would sink into it
just so you could just it's probably an
orgy floor
uh what's an origin like uh i'm guessing
just yeah everybody
all lay comfortable and [ __ ] each other
that's i've never been in it it was
probably something for the kids i don't
know i'm just calling it orgy floor but
i got to go into the
grotto and into the like the hot tub in
the pool way area and everything all of
it
so i was like holy [ __ ] this this lady
is legit
yeah for that at least so that's how we
start off the second time the tracy
morgan time a friend of ours
zumi back home he hit us up and he was
like yo
i ever tell you i think he's his sister
was bismarcky's businessman
that's great and so biz was djing
um the espy after party
i remember that fox and then he was also
djing the playboy mansion party that
they had before the espys i remember i
was i was like parking cars for that
aspect
really yeah something like helping
people get in and out of cars so he's
like um
we're coming out do you guys want to be
our guest to the playboy mansion
party and then we can't go to the espys
but we can we can go to the after party
that's where you want to go anywhere at
the sky bar at the uh
right there across the store at the
mondrian i'm like [ __ ] yeah and i've
already been to the playboy mansion so i
know the lay of the land i know where
we're going
i know we so we get on shuttles
uh which we first of all we're like how
the [ __ ] do you not ever tell us that
your sister works with like biz i mean
it's great
christ he's iconic so we get on the
shuttles at the mondrian
across from the store take us down
through the neighborhoods and i'm on the
shuttle with peyton manning we're on the
shuttle with
um antonio tarver at the time
uh olympic everybody yeah and uh it's an
amazing event yes
is so cool and we're in the back just
making people laugh
and we're having a good time because
we're not any of them you know what i
mean
so we get to the um levar arrington was
there and his wife
or girlfriend i mean man you we get
there
and um it's just everyone that's not
currently in season there was no nhl
players i think the nba players were not
there but there was football
um a couple other sports live boxing
h or espn boxing right there friday
night fights
um and i ended up being friend friendly
these this night with these two twins
these girls that were olympic athletes
who were i don't know if they were
swimmers or gymnasts they were cool as
[ __ ]
and they just roll with us and hung out
with us and you know we're seeing tom
brady and peyton manning you're also
realizing how big these [ __ ]
are you know
and you're seeing a guy like troy aikman
or or
[ __ ] peyton manning and you're
thinking well if he's that big and these
linemen are bigger than him like jesus
christ the size of these people so
there's
hot chicks and there's the playboy
bunnies and i'll tell you what the the
women that came with the men or were
invited were 10 times hotter than the
playboy girls they had body makeup on
and [ __ ]
there's the [ __ ] grottos going on
there people back there
peacocks you know what i mean like yeah
i've been i fed the monkeys they're like
what
because you can't park up there so
you know we're going around whatever and
then we turn the corner and here comes
tracy morgan and it's i mean it's like
you said it's a little over years ago
ryan
and it is boom and no one can believe i
know him and he's being so nice to me
there and he's like you're wrong with us
and then the rest of the night we just
walked around with tracy and let tracy
be tracy and hung out with him and he's
great
and and here's the other thing peyton
manning this is my boy ryan sickle he's
a hilarious comedian he would
he that's every single introduction no
matter who
it was he was [ __ ] having your back
on that i'm like what the [ __ ]
greatest dude he really is he is so
[ __ ] nice yeah i can't wait to run
into him again
i can't wait did i ever tell you my who
have no story
oh part of the reason why i moved here
oh i'll tell you the short version
because i know i i just always feel like
i told you all this stuff before but
i've been out here on vacation this is
my vacation in l.a
and uh before i ever moved here
and the two dudes i was out here on
vacation with my best friend
pete was my best friend in college
and he wound up setting a new jersey
state bench press record
like but the nicest guy in the world but
like
and again he looked like a cop but like
a jack copt but his buddy god rest his
soul my buddy
adam was one of the largest human beings
i'd ever seen in my life
who was like a prison guard and like
bounced in strip clubs
and he was so uh
had such a presence that wherever we
went with that dude we got noticed
and he would get offered jobs like he
would he took an extra cycle of steroids
because he was going to the mecca to go
to gold's gym like he was like i gotta
i'm gonna hang him bang a gold so i call
hogan
and he was like doing incline bench
presses at gold's with like 550 pounds
for reps just because he wanted
everybody to stare at him he was giant
remember when i introduced him
to like dice at the comedy store he was
like i want that guy to be my bodyguard
he goes he just has that kind of
did he no no because he went back to
jersey and that was it he was like
whatever
um but he was also hilarious like one of
the funniest dudes i ever met
like he was the one like when he would
there be fights and clubs
that he was bouncing out he would just
yell hot soup because people get out of
the way
he would just go hot soup hot soup
so that became his his his catchphrase
was hot soup that's so
good he would just try
he was but he before we knew it was
called the rear naked choke he would put
people in the sleeper
just for laughs he's like sally grotz he
would call me sally graziato because he
was a pro wrestler
he was like sally grotz he gives that
sleeper hold works
like he was just such an idiot he would
try pro wrestling moves on people and
stuff like that
just testing him out because he was so
big
he told me that he started doing
steroids when he was in high school he
was sally grotz
i never saw the 200's i go what he goes
i was 195 pounds when i started taking
anna draw and whatever else he was on he
goes three weeks later i was 320.
he weighed 320. he wanted he was at his
biggest probably like 360 pounds he was
of solid muscle no he had a belly oh
okay but like you know those big power
lifters
yeah like the the mountain that that
strongest yeah the guys that are uh yeah
you know squat rack and cheerleading
yeah my buddy robert my buddies
competes with the world's strongest man
my buddy robert is 400 pounds yeah those
guys gigantic gotcha so he was like a
minute
a smaller version of that you don't see
that every day anyway long story short
uh i don't want to put it so i'm at the
improv
like this dude is just going doing his
thing
and then uh i'm at the improv and i meet
a famous comedian i know i told this on
the uh i had to have told this on
um i think i probably told this on the
feast
so anyway we go to a strip club and
pete and adam pick me up anymore i'm
like we're gonna meet so and so at this
club and they're like no no we're not
he was like a famous comedian who was
just super cool to me so i walk in there
i'm a full-blown idiot i'm wearing a
hawaiian shirt
i got spain and pete with me but they're
just my friends
but then they had this one strip club
they had like these little velvet ropes
and i see the famous comedian he invites
me over for a drink
now adam and pete are star struck and
they don't come up so they're just like
standing in front of the velvet rope
because they're idiots
but if you're watching this from a
distance you might think they were my
bodyguards
you might think yeah okay i'm not saying
i never told anybody you might think
that
so then uh
we're hanging out i leave so now i'm
hanging out with do you not want to say
who the comedian
no okay yeah because i think maybe i did
in the past but
fine i'm the older i get the more i go
why ever mention somebody's
name do you know what i mean like you
never
so we're and i have a drink with them
and i'm like i'm totally moving here
this would never happen
in philly this is crazy and that dude
that comedian told me to move out here
he was like you're crazy enough to
actually make it in this business
so i'm talking to my buddies and then i
get a tap on the shoulder
and we're all like this is all so
surreal and crazy
and i'm i've seen this dude after when
hugh hefner came to the comedy store
and they swept the building like he was
ahead of state his security detail
and there are certain people that just
have a presence like you don't have to
be a gorilla to have a presence this
gentleman
uh was like balding mustache
a little bit older but he just had a
presence that if he asked you to do
something you said yes
and i looked down and hit a little lapel
with a plate a gold
bunny on it and he's wearing a suit like
you could join
this dude he looked like secret service
you know those dudes just have a
presence
and he said uh mr hefner would like to
invite you over for a drink
and i'm like what and he steps out of
the way
and then in the another booth was hugh
hefner with like the six or seven
blondes he was dating at the time
and like one brunette and i'm like and
my friends were like
what is going on here so now they're
doing the same thing and i sit down and
i'm like
you're sitting with hugh hefner yeah and
six girls
just the two of you and the girls yes
and why
okay here's the thing i
would lie as a younger man
here we go like the chunk and goonies
right like and i think it just comes
from insecurity
i know this is the honeydew i want to be
open as open as i can about myself
i think like for whatever reason in life
you we all get damaged in our own unique
way
and i don't i don't think for whatever
reason somewhere in my
psychological development i started
maybe felt like no
i think it's very human to just not feel
worthy you know
and especially when i got drunk i would
tell lies to try to get people to like
exaggerate or just get people to like me
give people
verbal reasons to hang out with me like
if you said
you were from kansas i'd be like i have
cousins in kansas oh yeah you know like
just because i wanted to connect and
it's very sad and needy
but this really happened right
i'm hanging out here's hugh hefner and
there's champagne and there's all these
girls
and i'm just like what is going on here
so then i'm talking to like the two
girls on the end it's like
girl me and then everybody else and i'm
making them laugh and stuff and then the
one girl
they're over here whispering then i did
it and then the one girl said but has he
introduced himself at all or anything
okay
have a drink and i'm like what is going
on here so then
the one girl is just staring at me
because i'm not lying at this point i
know not though i'm just being cool i'm
just being open
act like you've been there right but i'm
not like oh i'm doing this and that so
then the one girl asks me and she goes
now what's the name of the show that
you're on again and i go oh i'm not on a
tv show
right and then the other goes like there
we go oh
and what you know i want to do comedy
and stuff and then they're like okay and
then one girl's still being nice to me
then it's whisper down the line and then
the dude the shaved head secret service
yeah secret service dude comes back and
he just goes
thank you for your time and i went thank
you for your time i just got up
i was like how did this even happen but
the problems when i went back to philly
everybody was like that didn't happen oh
that's just like the time michael
jackson used your bathroom
chunking goonies he was like no the
fatalities are real
but it was one of the reasons why i
moved out here that's hilarious
because of a mistake yeah because what
it probably was
if i were to piece it together and i
don't know maybe they just saw me being
an idiot and wanted me
but you probably saw my buddies thought
i was somebody
i'm not and then at least i got to sit
down with an american icon for a few
minutes
i love it dude it's crazy that is good
but i was never to the mansion
yeah if you think about playboy it's a
little creepy dude no
it's very creepy yeah it's it's a whole
it was an empire built on that thing too
disgusting if you really think about it
john rowan had the best bit about that
oh they think i'm they're very
lucky talking about eating the bike
live girls i did always want to go to uh
a mid
what was it midsummer night's dream was
the party there polly would go
everything every year
i'll bet i'll bet yeah and it was that
party too was nuts because the front
lawn was
vendors but like high-end vendors like
cuban cigars
and [ __ ] and it was all free oh all of
it all of it
yeah absolutely all of it what a time
different times man well i love you
brother i love you too i wish you well
on this next little mini chat
i'll be back dude i hope so we got to do
our thing i know we're going to go
we got an email i know we sure did we
sure didn't well when life comes back
it's on bro good um i love you dude
thank you for doing this
and uh it was great to get you here i
mean this thing won't come out you'll be
gone when this comes out because
it's gonna come out a few weeks okay so
thank you dude um is there anything
you'd like to promote here if
because i i should be theoretically who
knows in this world but theoretically
i'm supposed to be at the arlington
drafthouse
the fifth and sixth of september that's
labor day weekend saturday and sunday
we're not doing i'm not doing friday i
don't know why
but saturday and sunday and then
the 16th through the 20th at the denver
comedy works south
i'm still i think i'm still supposed to
be there for that all right
so well thank you brother take care of
yourself
let's go get some lunch let's go um as
always ryan sickler on all social media
ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
you